Good evening.
This was a good
week for people who lie being revealed
as people who lie,
who then go on lying
or distorting the truth.
It began with court documents
revealing Fox's Tucker
Carlson was privately
skeptical of election
as contemptuous of the former president,
texting
someone even saying, quote,
I hate him
passionately talking about
the former president,
even as he indicated the view
to viewers, the opposite.
And as that news was hitting a Dominion
voting systems
lawsuit alleging
Fox broadcast election lies,
Carlson was on the air
lying about January six
The crowd was enormous.
A small percentage of them
were hooligans.
They committed vandalism.
You've seen their pictures
again and again.
But the overwhelming majority weren't
they were peaceful.
They were orderly and meek.
These were not insurrectionists.
They were sightseers.
That spectacle
using cherry picked footage.
House Speaker McCarthy released
only to him, was just the beginning.
The former president
went on a social network
without any evidence at all, a claim
that city, state
and federal prosecutors
are practicing quote,
good, all election interference,
all caps.
And then there was something else
that happened
that didn't get as much attention
but is important and involves
lies told by Janet Ellis,
one of the former president's
2020 election lawyers.
She's the one next to Sidney Powell
in this video behind Rudy Giuliani.
The press conference,
you may remember where his head
seemed to be leaking motor oil
What follows is a sampling of the lies
she told about the 2020 election that she
is now admitting were lies
Hillary Clinton still has not conceded
the 26th.
Why now.
We have affidavits from witnesses
we have voter intimidation.
We have the ballots that were manipulated
We have all kinds of statistics
that show that this was
a coordinated effort
in all of these states
to transfer votes
either from Trump to Biden
to manipulate the ballots
to count them in secret.
The election was stolen and President
Trump won by a landslide.
President Trump is right
that there was widespread fraud
in this election.
We have at least six states
that were corrupted,
if not more through the voting systems.
We know that President Trump
won in a landslide.
The outcome of this election
is actually fraudulent. It's wrong.
And we understand
that when we subtract
all of the illegal ballots,
you can see that President Trump
actually won in a landslide.
We have over 500,000 ballots
that were cast illegally
so we knew those were lies then.
But now under pressure,
she's admitted it.
Take a look.
This is a court document
that she herself signed, General
Lynn Ellis
in the Colorado disciplinary action
against her, a sworn statement.
In it,
she admits
that she knowingly misrepresented
the facts and those specific clips
that we just played.
They were part of a stipulation
she made as part of an agreement
to accept censure
and pay a small fine
in a disciplinary proceeding
brought against her in Colorado.
And what did she do afterwards after
she admitted that she,
quoting from the document now, quote,
made the following misrepresentations
while serving as counsel
for the Trump
campaign and personal counsel
to President Trump.
She went on Twitter right after
signing that and misrepresented
what she just sworn to.
Tweeting, quote, I would never lie.
Lying requires
intentionally making a false statement.
I never did
that, nor did
I stipulate to or admit that,
which is splitting hairs at best.
In that same document,
the one she signed,
she agreed
that the sanctions she got is merited
when lawyers, quote,
knowingly engage in, quote
unquote conduct that involves
dishonesty, fraud, deceit
or misrepresentation,
unless knowingly lying is in any way
meaningful way different
than intentionally lying
in any meaningful way,
then for all intents and purposes,
she's now intentionally
lying about being disciplined for
knowingly lying
to get that.